for four days and four nights pilot
Bertrand Piccard flew nonstop from
Hawaii to California his plane Solar
Impulse 2 goes 50 miles an hour that's
what a NASA test pilot would call Mach
0.065 when you fly a normal airplane you
go faster you have more control but you
have no freedom you need to refuel every
time but Solar Impulse is powered only
by the Sun and can stay aloft for days
theoretically it could fly forever
when you fly Solar Impulse it is slow it
is difficult to handle because you have
big wings sensitive to turbulence
because of the light weights but you are
free to fly forever so it's another way
to do the goal is not to reach
destination as fast as possible the goal
is to stay in the air as long as we want
covered in solar panels it's an X plane
to be sure one that could lead the way
to electric and possibly even
solar-powered
aviation the only reason to land is to
change the pilot when the pilot is too
tired
wired caught up with Picard and his
fellow pilot Andre Borschberg at Moffett
airfield in Palo Alto where the plane
was being inspected and recharged inside
it's custom inflatable hangar so what
you see here is a demonstration of
energy efficiency and in translates into
a very big wingspan this is bigger than
the 747 in terms of wingspan but it's
the weight of a car but the cockpit is
so small it makes a smart car look
spacious so here you have the de yoke
you have rudders it's mechanical like on
a normal airplane last year Borschberg
set a new record by flying solo for five
days and five nights from Japan to
Hawaii if this were successful we knew
that we had an airplane
sustainable you know in terms of energy
now the major question of the big
question was how to make the pilot
sustainable
well the cockpit may be miniscule but
it's built for the long haul here is the
toilet you see under the seat to avoid a
reenactment of the shining the pilots
use yoga self hypnosis and meditation to
stay relaxed and focused if you want to
sleep you'll resign the seeds world
records and while the globeadventures
are great but they're really out to
prove that solar and electric air travel
could be the future of aviation I bet
that in 10 years time within 10 years
time you'll have 50 people flying
commercial as passengers in an electric
aeroplane Solar Impulse 2 will be making
its way east across the United States
then hop the Atlantic on its way back to
Abu Dhabi
where the journey started